okay come on go go go let's go let's go
okay are you okay no I think this is you
craziness I can't do this we can't keep
running every [ __ ] day of our lives
let's bro we all may be here alive okay
we're good good baby this is good what's
so good about this [ __ ] we're all
[ __ ] bike socce waiting because haha
what are we supposed to do then huh even
were running because we haven't looked
at our other options yeah I didn't think
so so unless you have a better idea than
getting mauled to death sit down and
keep your mouth shut
so [ __ ] oh [ __ ] but what
what I'm sorry no no no okay okay hey
baby
this is what are you doing hey oh don't
it's okay okay okay you kids represent
the Fox market um dad don't you feel me
Superman
hope it'll use your shoe me them you
can't read it I'll give you got any well
you're gonna find one I do a [ __ ] eye
Louis not [ __ ] going back to my
[ __ ] wife right one more come on
market purchase one is on the back
Jesus is fun I know it'd be fun walking
with Isis bomb she's fun i knows you
Marcus Marcus go sit down
like you oh come here please
[Music]
baby from yogi
gay huh you'll have to worry I'm not
going
sorry
yeah no no no no no please don't do this
people
it was you
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
mission huh
you're [ __ ] stupid we have two rules
in this [ __ ] compound when our base
is compromised we move if you get bit
you die that's it
hey what's that
[ __ ] example yo whoa
don't relax what you talking about you
get bit it's not whoa it's nothing
seriously look if you have it no listen
you got busy yeah
I didn't get bit I did you I didn't get
one huh what listen [ __ ] what the [ __ ]
are you rody that's a bite mark is what
what about Community College would you
go like request your name shut the [ __ ]
up zombie expert listen okay this is a
taco shake character I've had it for
years you guys just know as well oh my
god oh my god what hey hey hey hey I
made the [ __ ] rules
it's like help it don't you think I
would've killed myself I know you know
I'm hurt my cash payment okay fine fine
all right we got it
what the one sign you're a zombie and
you're dead one
I'm cool hey okay
between
then a mystery real and then you're
gonna get you this online how can we get
you
what the [ __ ] your face man refused me
that's a little rule what about my face
you crazy you're done oh you know what
you never liked me did you you will
curly hair [ __ ] [ __ ] fat boy you know
what you little hot comb nightmare [ __ ]
you big hot here are you [ __ ] cages do
don't kill me
[ __ ] you - hey everybody gonna [ __ ]
there now we can't keep killing each
other every time we think selling this
[ __ ] you guys had me working my wife so
I'm running this [ __ ] okay you know what
you might know crack the [ __ ] up okay
you guys right left right so this is
where we're gonna do we're gonna go to
sleep
and figure this [ __ ] out in the morning
please back the [ __ ] up you up what
corner what is a house I am NOT a Bobby
yeah well then what the [ __ ] were you
doing I I am up again what just a homo
trying to get some big what's wrong here
this is ridiculous
I am again that's not how you say it dig
it dig hey you're not gay I'm not gay
what's this Lord can you do okay you're
putting it rich we'll see here ah
we all done okay you wanna make you my
coming-out moment a really terrible
memory I don't touch what it goes if
you're gay then you won't feel anything
if summer guy make it right when was the
last time you saw a woman make you
remember
why he would mean like nobody else okay
fine fine okay
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
cool